it's year three of danger at hogwarts
harry blows up his aunt marge leaves the
dursleys and boards the night bus it's
going to be a bumpy ride
where he learns about sirius black he's
a murderer back at hogwarts we meet a
flying creature named buckbeak who
punches malfoy in his dumb face buckbeak
is executed after this incident so
hermione punches malfoy in his dumb face
harry is attacked by a dementor during a
quidditch match after which professor
lupin teaches him the patronus charm and
gives him more magic chocolate he
doesn't house potter gets the marauders
map where he sees a thought to be dead
peter pettigrew turns out sirius black
is actually innocent and that ron's riot
is pettigrew in disguise my old friend
after lupin turns into a werewolf sirius
is captured and faces an unpleasant date
with the dementors not on harry and
hermione's watch literally they turn
back time and reveal that everything we
just watched was influenced by the
current harry and hermione we are
watching now they save buckbeak using
ultimate patronus charm to save sirius
and we end on a wacky freeze frame